69,000 fans I get crazy excited about
170 luxury suite I mean I can't wait to
see it once week three billion dollars
we're talking about a world-class
station the San Francisco 49ers are
kicking off this NFL season in a
brand-new state-of-the-art tech savvy
Stadium I think the fans are just gonna
love it Intel and s AP have signed on to
be ad partners at Levi's Stadium and
Yahoo is sponsoring the fantasy football
Lounge we have many more tech partners
than probably any other sports stadium
and that's because of everything of the
vision that we're trying to build we
wanted this place to be the physical
manifestation of Silicon Valley 2,200
flat screen TVs are mounted throughout
and if that's not enough fans can always
look to the endzone this is the largest
outdoor HD video board it's 48 feet tall
and 200 feet long no doubt the players
will run down the field they will look
up at the video board to see it's
chasing them most NFL stadiums can't
compete with the high-definition
experience fans now get watching
football at home and the new Niners
stadium is in Santa Clara 45 long miles
south of San Francisco in the heart of
Silicon Valley that means it has to woo
the smartphone set some stadiums where
you can't get a photo or your Instagram
or maybe in some cases not even make a
phone call because the Lions are tied up
or you know the bandwidth is not there
you're going to be able to check your
Twitter go to Instagram most importantly
send texts the Niners have a team of 25
engineer hired from top tech companies
like Facebook and Google those engineers
have built a special gameday app that
features instant replay and stack feeds
it's a cashless ticketless experience
where even concessions are ordered right
from your phone anywhere you sit in the
stadium you'll be able to order a beer
order a hot dog to your seat
whether you're you know front row or
whether you're in the upper deck and
that's that's half tech and that's half
Industrial Engineering Wi-Fi access
points are within 10 feet of every seat
and more than 200 phone charging
stations have been installed Internet
bandwidth 40 gigabytes that's
four times what the NFL mandates but
with all that what about traffic issues
and tech glitches there's going to be a
learning curve there's going to be a
learning experience for everybody we've
tested a lot of sound and we think that
it's going to be very loud bouncing
sound bouncing off the suite tower here
and coming back down on the field but
you won't know until you put 70,000 fans
in here one thing's for sure nobody's
more pumped than the players just can't
wait I mean I have dreams about this
statement